Сполучені Штати готуються передати протитанкові
ракетні комплекси Javelin Збройним силам України,
повідомив спецпредставник Держдепартаменту США
з питань України Курт Волкер. Що це за зброя,
і чи допоможе вона Україні?
Американські протитанкові ракетні комплекси Javelin
кваліфікують як летальне оборонне озброєння.
Вони призначені для ураження бронетехніки,
а також вертольотів та безпілотників, які перебувають на невеликій висоті.
Серед переваг комплексу - автономна система
наведення та можливість вражати ціль згори,
тобто з найменш захищеного напрямку.
Про оборонну зброю Україна просила своїх західних партнерів
кілька років. У Києві переконані:
постачання цих протитанкових ракетних комплексів
дозволить війсковим більш ефективно стримувати
агресію Росії та підтримуваних нею
сепаратистів на Донбасі.
Оборонну зброю Київ отримає від Сполучених Штатів безкоштовно,
заявляють у Києві. Тим часом американські ЗМІ
зазначають, що йдеться про продаж протитанкових ракет.
Зокрема, наприкінці минулого року
телеканал ABC, посилаючись на свої джерела
у Державному департаменті, повідомив
про угоду на 47 мільйонів доларів,
яка передбачає постачання 210 протитанкових ракет
та 35 пускових установок. Якщо президент
Дональд Трамп схвалить план, документ ще має
затвердити Конгрес.
У розпорядженні українських військових Javelin,
як прогнозують у Генштабі, мають з’явитися
до літа. Точних дат у Вашингтоні поки не називають,
проте наголошують, що для передачі Україні
озброєння потрібен час. Зокрема,
за словами спецпредставника Курта Волкера,
слід підготувати об’єкти та визначити способи передачі.
За даними американських ЗМІ, Сполучені Штати
готові передати Javelin Україні за умови,
що зброю триматимуть подалі від лінії фронту.
У Вашингтоні побоюються, що надання такої зброї
призведе до ескалації конфлікту на Сході України.
А також того, що установка потрапить до рук бойовиків,
які зможуть використовувати її вже проти
українських танків.